all right garrett garrett where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
uh i grew up here in the bay area uh
more on the coast rather than the berry
per se a little town called half moon
bay
yeah just south of san francisco yes
it's in between santa cruz and
san francisco on highway one and tell me
about your family you had both your
parents when you were a kid
yes i did they divorced when i was five
um my dad was kind of like a rough
tough uh hippie like biker guy and my
mom
was uh like she worked for kaiser
hospital she's the one who kind of
the breadwinner who's uh you know she
kept things going she was uh the
responsible one
and how would you describe your
childhood uh you know i was um
a little bit uh you know it was a little
bit rough definitely a broken home but
uh
we at the same time we uh you know i was
fortunate to uh i worked on a fishing
boat as a deckhand i got to do a lot of
things a lot of kids don't
get to experience i'd say you know
especially in this
day and age of video games and computers
and whatnot i was uh
able to experience quite a few things
and traits that uh
just a lot of kids don't have the
opportunity to do did you finish high
school i did
good for you and uh where'd your life go
after you left home
uh you know i also got into the
narcotics business um
just of course i'm from northern
california so uh and the weed industry
blew up and uh you know i did quite well
for that person time
but i was young and dumb the money that
i made off that i kind of just had more
fun than saved and put away
so you know i kind of just
was the one big party for a long time
did you do a jail time yeah i did jail
time yeah prison time yeah for drugs
yeah yeah and uh so you're in the
tenderloin now how long have you been
down here you know i don't
sleep in the tenderloin or stay in the
center lane i tried to get in get out um
you know it's where there are some
resources you can uh you know
like uh shower clean up what not but
it's it's it's a pit
so yeah so where do you stay you know i
stay up in buena vista park
up on hate street it's kind of a little
bit out of the crowd that way you can
actually like you know have some peace
when you go to sleep and
you don't worry about losing your stuff
every night and getting stolen or beat
up or whatever
yeah yeah a lot of crazy [ __ ] happens
here yeah for sure
he knows um some people are wondering
are they fake crazy are they momentarily
homeless going through a struggle or
like a lot of people seem like they like
it out here
okay what the harder drug use started
for you when
yeah about 16 17. um you know i
fit the once again i fit the profile i
got scoliosis back surgery
when i was 15 2001 and
i got hooked on uh pain medication and
from there it turned into
heroin and heroin turning into fentanyl
so fentanyl is your drug now
yeah and you're smoking it or i
yeah unfortunately it's a dangerous drug
yeah it is i've known a lot of people
die out here
yeah yeah quite a few and how are you
supporting yourself now
uh right now mainly uh boosting and
small uh drug deals here and there
yeah you get caught for boosting yet
you know i've got caught one time and uh
due to the kobe right now it's really
hard to go to jail
thank god and so they just tell you to
not come back
yeah yeah they don't want to hold you
yeah it's very hard to go to jail right
now you have to be gifted to go to jail
right now
so all right and not to mention too san
francisco county and alone it's kind of
like a safe haven here
um where as opposed you go to the east
bay you go to alameda or you go to san
mateo county
residing next door it's uh yeah they're
really um
prostitution drugs anything like that
here they tend to look a blind eye
towards so
yeah how old are you i'm 34 34 you have
kids
i don't been married or anything like
that never married i was in a
uh like i said a minute earlier to you i
was in quite a long relationship with uh
my previous girlfriend out of the last
year and uh i met her in rehab we were
both clean for quite a few years
and then uh just relapsed he followed
along with me unfortunately and
and then we just yeah the relationship
with the hill and that really that was a
downer on me so that's kind of
that's what got you to relax yeah that's
what got me relapsed and that's kind of
where
you know kind of not my excuse or
anything that's what led me to
where i'm at now right yes that way for
a lot of people
yeah so do you have uh good friends
you know i do have good friends thank
god i do have good friends and uh like
they're uh supporting me right now
getting back into rehab and whatnot so
i'm on my way
out of this mess right now so good for
you that's great yeah
definitely on third base getting out of
here what's been the most painful
part of your life that breakup or you
know that breakup too and i gotta say
too is um
just the uh at least for me now as i'm
getting older
uh is just my cycles i go through i do
really really well i'm sober you know i
have a good job it's a white ticket fans
whatever
have whatever and then i throw it all
away like self-sabotage
and just to come out here and do this
it's not fun you know right and uh i
don't know so i'm trying to figure out
how i keep going through that cycle and
what's causing me to do it you know is
it
a little bit of everything society
whatnot or is it uh
do you feel loved by both your parents
when you were a kid
yeah i do it took me a long time to
realize that they did the best they
could
you know as i got older i didn't realize
that when i was younger but yeah they
did
yeah um weird way of showing it but yeah
they did
right and do you feel like you are able
to love yourself as you're as an adult
i'm getting getting better yeah yeah
it's the learning practice it's a
struggle for everybody
yeah i'm getting better though yeah but
and you've been through rehabs and
things like that yeah i've been to a lot
of
rehabs
how's that been that how's that
experience been for you uh you know i
have i like i'm not a big bible or a
thumper but i mean
i i could probably quote you the book
back to back but uh
you know if it works uh i i take a
little bit of everything what works and
what doesn't and apply it
and when i do that i seem to stay sober
and work a good program so
i am a testament that uh if you want to
get clean and sober there are resources
out there in the work
yeah if you want it it takes a little
bit of work on your part but you got to
want it you know
what emotions do you deal with most you
go through depression or anxiety or
anxiety for sure i've always had that
just i was born with over anxiety you
know
um always self analyzing myself am i
doing this right not right but yeah
uh and then i said she was a depression
but yeah and then anger of not reaching
my potential in life where i'm at you
know right
kind of like in my prime and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm homeless yeah you look like a
yeah you could be like you know on top
of the world right now right right
i found you on the street yeah early in
the morning here right yeah on the
tender into the tender
kind of embarrassing family like this
but the shame a big uh part of this
yeah it's totally i think it's a shame
shame is a big part for everybody yeah
for me like uh i try not to live like
you know fit the part like it's morning
time right now you kind of caught me but
i was like oh [ __ ]
i try to not have that
what do you do for food you go to the
the feedings yeah i do
um not all the time but um mainly um i
like to eat healthy like when i'm sober
and feel like a real big health food net
so that just like um makes it kind of
difficult around the kitchen i can't
like cook right so now you're eating
this the kind of food i like so yeah i
don't know like
i'll hit whole foods trader joe's a lot
and i have to
you know they're halfway decent food and
i have a buddy who works at a um
like it's a mom and pop locally um
locally owned and like organically uh
grown um shop here in the city
and i'm able to get a lot of like my
health food stuff i like yeah
so you told me in the car that you're
supporting yourself by uh boosting yeah
mainly in boosting right now yep
i have a couple different um fences you
know um their orders
um the fence is somebody who'll buy this
stuff from correct yeah high-end alcohol
you know
um certain uh makeup's a big one
uh medicine's a big one too actually so
um
if db on any given day i can make two
three hundred dollars
and that'll support your drug habit yeah
you know and i like to say to you i like
to get a hotel room i can just like
sleep on the street like you know have a
shower in the kitchen so it
yeah two three hundred dollars goes
quick yeah you know it does and is your
family
they know you're out here they do they
don't know uh
right now that i'm as bad as it is right
now they think you know
i was just on unemployment this past
year and whatnot and they don't know the
full
extent of it yeah yeah i didn't go back
for christmas or anything because i
didn't you know i could tell just by
looking at me i'm
you know 20 pounds 30 pounds under
weight and
bags under my eyes yeah it's just now
that they you know they're alcoholics
and down cells too but
right it just it wouldn't be pretty what
have you learned from all your mistakes
um i gotta say is uh
don't beat yourself up too much just get
back up and you know
keep trying yeah don't give up i think
believing in yourself is a big part
absolutely totally because it's so easy
to get down on yourself yeah and
as much as you look at your faults and
where you went wrong you also just you
gotta look at
well your rights and what you have done
right and now you can do it again and
yeah especially if you're like a
perfectionist or something like that a
little bit yeah i got that a little bit
in me too yeah you so hard on yourself
right and
that just is the cycle of destruction
going doesn't it
totally
and then it's true like especially what
i've noticed if you look at the
homeless population too it's like a lot
of it i don't know if it's mental health
issues which is a big one
that's a big one but uh i definitely say
like eighty percent of people are
addicted to some kind of narcotic
or alcohol whatever it is there's uh 80
i would
i would think about 99 you're right yeah
yeah you're right yeah exactly no
you can you can say drug addiction is
the issue but i really think mental
health is the real issue behind that
true and then behind that yeah is
self-medicating with it
the lack of love and childhood is the
core of it all i think yeah exactly so
cause you can have two parents in your
life and you can say they loved you but
you can still grow up to be an adult and
not feel like you were ever loved
totally
i think that's the the most common story
i
yeah whether the people understand it
themselves or not right i think you're
right yes
common denominator but people just say
homelessness and drug addiction is the
problem
don't really understand it right
so do you have people on the street here
that you trust there's i got a very very
small circle and uh
you know they're uh they're not really
on the street though like i am
um just local dealers and stuff like
that who got their [ __ ] together excuse
my language but yeah
and what what kind of dreams did you
have as a kid of doing the job i grew up
surfing and i used to be in the nssa as
a junior
right um but right now i don't know if
you ever heard of mavericks yeah you
should be surfing right there right now
we got my friends
here it's the time of year for it yeah
and yeah i've been missing it and
seeing my buddies and stuff you know
send me a
show me back on youtube what i'm missing
and like oh my god
and you surf those big these giant waves
you know i haven't been quite those
giant waves but uh you know ocean beach
uh
training ground good place for them but
i was well on my way there i hope to get
back there soon get back in shape and
is there is there also like a
self-destruction
streak that runs in these guys that surf
those giant waves because that's
threatening your life every time you do
it for sure
it's a little healthier though i mean
yeah no it's it's
it's a it's probably a healthier form of
health reform definitely
yeah yeah i understand challenging
yourself but that that seems like a lot
of those guys end up dying right
some of them don't say a lot not a lot i
shouldn't say a lot but it's happened
right
yeah also keeps you in credible shape
totally
yeah yeah it's probably a very healthy
way to challenge yourself yeah it's just
a lot healthier
as long as you don't end up underwater
right yeah
excellent so um where where do you see
your chances are getting out of here i
mean
you know pretty good i will uh say that
i've done it before
you know um and i this has gone on far
too long i'll admit it it's
going on my year now supposed to be
maybe a two three month thing
yeah and i just keep saying next month
next month next month you know
yeah that's the drug just don't let
yourself become a 60 year old man
yeah no no you're going to see a lot of
them yeah like i said just embarrassing
for me to even
be telling you this stuff you know i'm
i'm much better than this yeah i can i
can totally see you cleaning up and
getting your
yeah getting your life straight thank
you yeah i'm much better than this
though
what's the most important lesson you've
learned from all this
there's quite a few uh you know um
whether it's through any kind of
community or any kind of like uh support
you have
you know like use that support really um
don't neglect it or you know take
advantage of it absolutely
i see a lot of people that ask for help
yeah and then when they get offered the
help
yeah they can't accept it right that's
you and it's like out and they disappear
and yes and like
you what here's here it is exactly you
can't accept it
can't accept it totally i see that i see
that left and right i can't tell you how
many times i see that that self-sabotage
thing kicks in and
yeah big time the thing that you dream
about and say you want
is that here but you just you can't do
it you run away from it right
yeah totally i'm i'm definitely guilty
of that i think everybody down here
yeah i think everybody in the world is
guilty of it so yeah one way or another
true that we're our own versus enemies
yes we are everywhere we go there we are
all right garrett thank you so much for
talking with me yeah i appreciate it i
wish you the best of luck now yeah yep
thank you thank you
you